حظر انشطه المنظمات الدينيه التي لها صله
بروسيا هذا ما ادلبي الريس الاوكراني
بلودي ميرسي في خطابه المسائي
والدفاع تعليمات للحكومه بان تقترح على
البرلمان مشروع قانون بشان حظر الانشطه في
اوكرانيا للمنظمات الدينيه التابعه لمراكز
النفوذ في روسيا
اكد كذلك انه سيكون هناك تحقيق في وضع
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الاوكرانيه بشان وجود
صله قانونيه مع بطريرك موسكو تاتي هذه
الاجراءات في اعاقب عمليات دعم النفاذتها
اجهزه الامن الاوكرانيات في تشرين الثاني
نوفمبر في الدير الرئيسي في العاصمه ومكان
اقامه الرئيس الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه
الاوكرانيه بسبب شبهات بصلات مع مسكوه هذا
ودعمه الكنيسه الورثوذكسيه في روسيا غزوه
اوكرانيا اذا يعتبروا البطريركيين مؤيدا
مهما للرئيس الروسي الذي قتل
الدفاعي الامامي للعالم الروسي العالم
الروسي ليس فقط روسيا انه في كل مكان يعيش
فيه الناس الذين نشاوا على تقاليد
الارثوذكسيه وتقاليد الاخلاق الروسيه
تصريحات ادت الى اعلان كنيسه الارثوذكسيه
الاوكرانيه التابعه لبطريرك موسكو عن قطع
علاقاتها مع روسيا في نهايه ايرميو بسبب
غزو اوكرانيا مع العلم ان اوكرانيا دوله
ذات اغلبيه ارثوذكسيه